hey guys Pete here alright this will be
my recap and review for 20 season 3 part
6
I apologize up front for my voice I am
still nursing this cold and this is your
spoiler warning if you haven't seen part
6 yet you will want to stop watching
this video now just a quick reminder if
you want to skip over the scene by scene
breakdown you can go to the description
and there will be a timestamp link that
will take you to the end discussion so
we start off about half an hour later
than the end of part 5 and we know this
because the security guard or the cop
comes back to doggie coupe who hasn't
left the site of the statute eventually
he gets dougie coupe home and as Jamie
II is getting him into the door the cop
guy hands her a manila envelope someone
has left outside on their stoop the most
interesting thing here is that the
officer says he seems a little
disoriented and Naomi Watts says that's
on a good day remember this is still the
first full day of agent Cooper living
inside Dougie's life so although we'll
probably never know what the original
dougie was like it helps to understand
why he's lasted as long as he has in
this state like obviously there were you
know strange episodes going on in dougie
world
Jamie II brings up Dougie's car which
we'll get into in a bit but overall just
seems concerned about how dougie coupe
is doing next they have a sandwich
together and she says she's going to
take him to see dr. Benton at lunchtime
tomorrow this makes it sound like he's
visited this doctor before she sends
dougie coupe upstairs to say goodnight
to sonny jim and i know more and more
people are growing tired of watching
coop like this but I still love watching
Kyle MacLachlan
acting in these scenes he does a great
job of looking lost and clueless sonny
jim is in bed reading what looks like a
Hardy Boys book he directs dougie coop
to sit on the bed next to him and he
won't take a chip from him when he
offers since he says he's already
brushed his teeth he asses if he can
leave his cowboy light on and if dougie
coop will stay with him until he falls
asleep they have a little batter battle
with the clapper on the cowboy light
that I talked about in my top moments
video
eventually get interrupted Jamie eat
downstairs decides to take a look inside
that unmarked manila envelope and this
leads to that interruption she yells to
tell dougie coupe to get downstairs and
this definitely disappoints sonny jim
jamie presents dougie coupe with the
photo of him and jade and he brightens
up and he says jade smiles and then
before he says Jake gave two rides
picture is of the real dougie and there
were in different clothes than what we
saw whenever we met that you know met
her the first time in the show so this
isn't from the day of the switch but not
sure if that's important like he had an
ongoing relationship with her Janie is
furious that a he hasn't contacted the
guys he owes money to and be that he's
been sleeping Jade I love how know it
Naomi Watts is fuming in this section
and you admit you know her the phone
rings and Janey takes charge of the
situation
after representing the guy on the phone
she sets a meet for noon 30 at the park
and she says she'll be the one with the
red purse she scolds w coop tells him
she can't take him to see the doctor now
because she has to go meet his friends
and then reminds him that he better get
his work done because they can't afford
for him to lose his job it's worth
noting here that even though she is
really pissed she's still protective and
gives him a kiss on the head before she
walks off the transition shot is a
little bit out of place it's the
stoplight turning red like we've seen
before and we hear that electrical hum
while it's on the screen before we cut
away from there we see Mike appear to
dougie coop from the red room again he
tells him that he has to wake up wake up
then he says don't die three times while
making a motion with his arm not sure if
this is supposed to be a spell or what
it is but he's definitely on dougie side
we see that dougie coop then starts
seeing little dots of light on his case
files and begins going to work marking
the documents we see him following cues
and making marks that look like line
scribbles ladders and stairs there's
some music playing in the background
here as he works and I mentioned this
because I brought it
than my 10 things you might have missed
video from the last episode that it
might be an indication since there was
no music at first when he came back
maybe this is an indication and when
we're seeing signs of his return to his
old self granted he's still completely
in la-la land but he is working so
that's something improvement I just get
happy when Albert is on the screen
anytime and I perked up right away when
I realized he was driving in a car
talking to Gordon Cole reminds Albert
that the work he's doing is very very
important to Mary's and that he'll be
thinking of him as he's drinking this
fine Bordeaux Albert responds that he
loves a night on the town when it's 34
degrees outside and raining when he gets
out of the car he delivers what may be
his best line of all time as he raises
his umbrella he growls [ __ ] Gene Kelly
you [ __ ] and then keeps on
walking
he enters max Vaughn's bar which looks
like it is probably in turn eastern US
city like Philadelphia or somewhere
nearby but really it could be anywhere
that the temperature drops too close to
freezing
there's nothing clear it just reminded
me of something Eastern get a great
suspenseful shot as he approaches and I
had a pretty good idea of what was
coming concerning this doesn't look like
a Sarah Palmer type of place sure enough
we see a woman with a platinum blonde
wig from behind and he says her name
Diane the way it was set up it was just
like come on say it say it come on just
say it Albert say it anyway she turns
around what's a cigarette in hand we see
that it's Laura Dern and that she is the
woman who agent Cooper was always
talking to through the tape recorder
through distant and sad looking eyes she
simply says hello Albert
and then we cut away the transition here
scene here is what looks like a logging
operation we get a panning shot that
includes a quarterback henchman with
automatic weapons a new character red
and the sounds of someone making strange
excited noises in the background we find
out that Richard horn is making the
noises as a result of trying out a
sample of a new batch of drugs I discuss
red in the top moments video so I'll
just
reenter
that he's an intriguing care cause the
drug Sparkle and he seems to be honored
himself he also seems to like to throw
around his weight in the conversation by
calling Richard small-time and Kidd Reds
basically testing Richard by the things
he says and he also provides some nice
comedic moments in his whacked-out state
I laughed where he got a little too
excited then had to explain that he had
a problem with his liver anyways they go
back and forth right ask him if he's got
this under control threatens that he
will be watching him and that he'll saw
his head open and eat his brains if he
asked him over he then does his coin
flip magic trick to drive the sentiment
home it's a pretty cool trick and it
seems to really piss Richard off Richard
takes to his pissed off at Miss on the
road with him and basically stews his
way along down the road from there we
visit the fat trout trailer park which
is located in a different place from
when we saw it into your meadow and fire
walk with me I mentioned this before I
don't know exactly what the story is as
far as how it got there
but it's definitely in a different place
we see Carl rod getting into a van with
another new character named Mickey he's
running up and he wants to see if Carl
will give him a ride into town because
he has to pick up
Linda's mail at the post office Linda is
of course one of the names the giant
mentions in the beginning of part one so
I imagine everyone in the fandoms ears
sort of perked up when we heard this
they talked on the ride and we find out
that Carl goes into town just about
every day that Linda was likely wounded
in the war she has gotten an electric
wheelchair and that Carl has been
smoking for 75 years now that seemed
like a long really long time to me and I
looked it up and Harry Dean Stanton is
actually 90 years old
so if Carl's the same age as him then
that's definitely possible but cut to
the double arm where Heidi is giggling
while a customer is talking we see
Shelley there behind the counter at the
same time and she's listening in we get
a little bit of background here the
customers name is Miriam she works at a
school love's double our cherry pie and
leaves a tip that Shelly
Hannie think is beyond her means this
makes us wonder if this is who red
mentions to richard in drug deal scene
next we see carl sitting on a bench
enjoying the smoke in a cup of double
our coffee
Mickey's no longer with him well he's
sitting there looking at the trees we
see his face sort of change to something
like uneasiness I would say and then we
see a mom and her boy come by they're
playing a game where the boy runs for a
bit and stops and then the mom comes and
runs after and grabs ahold of it splits
the smile back on Carl's face but it's a
little bit ominous at the same time we
get some shots going back and forth to
Richard horn driving down the road being
zooted it and also still fuming about
how red talked to him then we get a
full-on scene with him where he comes up
to an intersection which I've read is
the same one that you know in fire walk
with me where Mike pulled up to Leland
and Laura and was shouting into the car
seeing that there's cars there stopped
at the sign he says after this and
decides to go around rather than stop it
at the same time we see the mom and son
come to the crosswalk the driver first
in line at the stop sees them and waves
them on and then in a brutal shot we see
Richard run him down several people at
the intersection witnessed this and horn
just keeps driving shouting out hey I
told you to get out of the way and we
also see Miriam spot Richard driving
away and the two of them actually make
eye contact back at the scene we see the
mother breaking down with her child in
her arms while a small crowd gathers
having heard the screams Karl walks
towards the intersection for what
strikes me as a very important sequence
as he looks on he sees a yellow light
leave the boy's body travelling upwards
until it disappears he then walks over
and what looks like an effort to comfort
her we then get a shot at the telephone
pole was this you know the same markings
as the one from the fat trout in fire
walk with me but I'm not gonna get into
all that but this this is a telephone
pole similar to one we've seen before it
it's not in the same place but it does
have the same number
six plate on the front of it and a
smaller plate with the number three two
four eight one zero when the pan and
when the camera pans up to the power
lines we have that electrical hum or
what's that's you know that's what I'm
gonna call it anyways it's not quite a
home it's something like a crackle or
whatever but it's called a hum that we
associate with the lodges while the
sound plays the screen fades to black so
no room above a convenience store here
but interesting that they're calling
back to that kind of imagery visit mr.
Todd in his office where he's working on
his computer as he's answering emails or
something we see a red square appear on
his screen we aren't sure where it came
from but he seems to know what it means
and he goes directly to his safe pulling
out an envelope while he's you know
using a tissue so that he doesn't leave
any prints on it's a plain envelope it
has a strange black dot or mark on it
back at Rancho Rosa the police have been
you know they've responded to the scene
where Dougie's car blew up we see them
collecting evidence and that the front
end of you know the front bumper with
the putt the Dougy lb plate on it has
ended up on the drugged-out mother's
roof we see her inside shouting 1 1 9
and I noticed it was similar to the last
time we saw her do that because there
was a pill in the bottle so I went back
and checked and it's exactly the same
footage from part three if you put both
clips side by side it's clear that it's
the same shot but I don't know what that
means but yeah they just reuse that same
footage now if that's a clue or not
that's up for discussion next we meet
another new character at a motel in what
looks like the Las Vegas area he's a
dwarf who appears to be rolling a pair
of dice and recording the outcomes and
an opal as he's doing this we see the
envelope from mr. Todd's desk it's
slipped underneath his door he pulls out
the contents and we see that it's a
picture of Lorraine and the real dougie
and Ike the spike which we learn is his
name from the credits grabs a nice pic
off his desk and studies the pictures
before stabbing them both in their faces
dougie coop has made it back to his
office with his old black suit on
Case Files and his very own coffee for
the day he still hasn't figured out the
elevator but eventually gets going in
the right direction
his boss calls him into his office to
look at the case files and we see
outside Tom Sizemore's
character Tony is watching from his own
office at first but or Bushnell thinks
dougie coop needs professional help
after looking at the drawings but he
looks again and makes sense of what Doug
heap scratched down there we hear some
music creep into the background as he
starts to figure it out but don't get
any real indication ourselves of what
he's discovered he says it's disturbing
so we assume some sort of fraud or
misconduct is probably going on from
Tony or something like that I mean
obviously coop called him a liar and
that is probably true Jamie E is at the
park with her red purse this is a great
scene where naomi watts lays out her
terms and ends up paying them twenty
five thousand instead of the fifty two
that they were asking for for the juice
and then gives them a proper talking to
that was just absolutely awesome she
says we're living in a dark dark age and
you are part of the problem now I
suggest you take a good look at
yourselves because I never want to see
either of you again and then she does
this awesome shuffle as she goes back to
the car and we hear one of the guys say
tough game like the spike shows up at
Lorraine's office and goes on a Gori
Tere he quarters arraign stabbing her
repeatedly while twisting the icepick in
her chest until she expires he notices
that another woman has come to the door
and saw that what he'd done so he chases
after her and puts her down off-camera
we see him covered in blood walking away
looking pretty much unfazed about what
he's just done but then he gets
instantly upset when he realizes he's
bent the icepick Richard Horan pulls up
off the road somewhere on the outskirts
of town I guess there's a point here
where we see the reflection of a
telephone pole you know it's the lines
in his windshield and hear that
electrical hum before he stops the truck
and sort of does a half-assed washing of
the blood that's on his grill he's
outside the
are the electrical lines and pole aren't
in the frame which doesn't mean they're
not there but it might be of interest
because they're definitely noticeable in
the reflection but then we don't really
see much going on when he gets out next
we get another big payoff this time via
hawk
the mystery of the log lady where she
said that he you know something was
missing and it had something to do with
his heritage all comes together as he's
in the bathroom at the sheriff's
department he drops a coin it's a
buffalo head or Indian Head nickel that
makes him look around he sees a Nez
Perce manufacturing label on the door
which is the tribe that he's from it's
also related to his heritage he looks up
and he finds missing screws starts
tearing apart the door only briefly
slowed down by Chad being a douche and
he finds what looks to me to be pages
out of Loris secret diary no I said in
my big moments video that this might be
where Mike had been in the bathroom I
went back and looked at that scene and
there's really nothing conclusive if
anything it kind of disproves the theory
the bathroom doesn't look the same and
the way this the scenes cut it's like he
goes in and comes right out and nothing
else happens I'll talk a little bit more
about these pages and what they might
mean after the review next we see doors
come in and Frank comforts her and gets
her out of the control room after she
leaves Chad resumes being super douchey
and the woman at the switchboard says
that they had a child who committed
suicide Frank indoors which obviously
could be important about things but it's
important here because Doris used to be
kind of normal and now she acts like she
does after this happened what Chad says
here could be important he says that the
true moon kid killed himself because he
couldn't take being a soldier so there
may be a connection here with Linda and
Frank Truman's son but hey you know I
don't know after that the episode ends
back in the way we were used to
a musical performance at the Roadhouse
so this was quite a good episode I
mentioned that in the right other video
if you skipped the scene-by-scene
welcome to the video a lot of big stuff
here obviously there was a lot of us who
thought that Albert and Cole were
talking about Diane so that's a great
payoff to see that happen the little
disappointing that we didn't get to
learn anything more about her but you
know she's on board now so let's see
where that takes us
also the hawk discovery that's been a
lingering question and there really
weren't very many good theories about it
in my opinion I mean I didn't have any
so I can't say but yeah there was a lot
of kind of goofy things bouncing around
and it's good to see that it was pretty
simple I do think that those are pages
from Laura's diary because that's
something that's a part of the show that
everyone sort of knows about if you're
confused about why or what think back to
when she originally takes the diary away
she did that and fire walk with me
because she realized someone was tearing
pages out when we saw that the
assumption was is that bob was doing
that through Leland and then he was
probably I mean he was taking the pages
but we thought maybe he was doing that
because there was stuff about him
written now that still could be the case
I doesn't make sense in this narrative
but it you know
it could be that he was pulling out
stuff that was coming from her dreams
like Annie's message and possibly other
things that we don't even know about yet
so the Mike thing doesn't look like it
was probably him that put it there but
it could be a number it could be
explained in a number of ways that would
make sense
don't forget Leland was at the police
station several times so they could have
hit it to make sure that he wasn't you
know wasn't found on his body so on and
so forth either way I think those are
Loras pages but it could be something
else and if you have an alternate theory
just let me know in the comments I also
think it's interesting that we finally
made it to fat trout that was something
I had been
and really mostly I mean I loved the
fact trout deer meadow thing because of
it was just a good part of fire walk
with me but also after learning more
about call rod in the secret history
this place really seemed interesting I
don't want to get into it too deeply
because it might spoil the book for some
people or whatever but the fact that he
sees this is a strong indication that
when Cooper does I guess if he does
regain his old self or whatever you want
to call it goes back to his old self he
may be improved over what we knew of him
before you know I mean like Carl rod was
a child when he went away and he came
back and he can obviously see thing the
log lady can have messages that you know
we saw one pan out in this episode right
so that's real stuff that's happening
you know I mean she's not crazy it's
related to the fact that she went away
whenever she was a child or was abducted
however you want to look at it so we had
Phillip Jeffries out there on the
fringes of things he's been there and
back we assume and Cooper as well so you
know that that's a whole nother kind of
dimension to this whole lodge mythology
I guess you would say named Naomi Watts
really did a great job and I think it's
pretty interesting towards the whole
dougie storyline how protective she is
of him and that he you know like she's
his real wife you know everything like
that came up for a while that that might
not be because we couldn't really figure
out how evil coop had manufactured
dougie and just slipped him into a life
because the original dougie that we've
seen looks
I mean he's played by a Kyle MacLachlan
so he looks like the other two coops
right so yeah I think if anything we
found out that she is on his side he has
had problems in the past that make it
seem like he's just having a relapse or
some sort and that she is really
protective and can actually help him out
moving forward right is an interesting
character I'm not sure if he's anything
but a zooted out crazy person but there
may be some other stuff going on and
obviously whenever Richard is on his
drug he basically commits murder
hit and run fashion and we hear sound
cues that make us think about the lodges
and things like that so not exactly sure
where that's headed but Richard horn we
know is important because of the giant
we've heard about Linda now we'll see
who she is really soon so those two are
taking us somewhere we can see that
Richards path is definitely one of
destruction perhaps Linda will be you
know the other side of the coin there
like the spike was just crazy didn't see
that character coming the death scene
was brutal I mean it's just over the top
gore and there was a weird juxtaposition
there you know the character was funny
and the way he was presented but equally
if not more so just viciously brutal so
two interesting saying I don't think
that dougie coupe would be very good
match for him at this point and he's
definitely on his way to find him in the
near future so that's something that's
gonna probably come to a head the red
fox that set that whole thing in motion
is a mystery I might get into that and
some other stuff that I've been looking
at I mean we're supposed to think that
evil coupe sets at but we know evil
coupe is locked up so if somebody else
sent in the red square the person that
he talked to on his briefcase before or
whoever he was communicating to you on
the phone obviously Phillip Jeffries
comes to mind but I wouldn't say that
there's any clear evidence that Phillip
Jeffries is still around other than evil
coupe talked to someone who may or may
not have been Jeffries on the phone so
yeah a lot to think about a lot going on
here I guess you could say that we are
through the first third maybe the first
act I don't know if it's broken up that
neatly or whatever but it's good to see
dougie coop making some progress I think
that the light at the end of the tunnel
was there for that I think there's
probably something going on with sonny
jim but it's still a little bit unclear
and i think his wife just sort of
solidified the fact that she's on his
side now we haven't heard anything about
the other stuff in South Dakota lately
so maybe we'll see a trip back to that
and also I'm hoping that we're gonna get
more about
the garment ball Xia and the box
investigation in New York so let me know
what you guys think let me know any
questions comments you have you know
I'll do a Q&A later this week hopefully
by then I won't be sick anymore
thanks for all your wishes and stuff in
the comments at the last video I think I
might do that again I like that it's a
little bit easier to do and gives me
time to watch it once and then go ahead
and break it down on the next one
so please like this video and please
subscribe to my channel thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon